today I'll stick to football we are back
on YouTube baby so go check it out on
the bleach report YouTube channel
mellows here Connors here we're gonna
talk about everything that's happening
in the world of the NFL Draft we're
gonna give you our top 32 big boards and
close the show out with draft on draft
but Melo read the news for me but me
doing this all the time yeah
January 4th I believe that is tomorrow
when you are listening to this that is
on Saturday we are doing a Kansas City
meet up Matt and I will be at char bar
at 1:00 p.m. with a lot of different
kind of Kansas area Kansas City area
guys let's try that one again there to
talk football with us not just Kansas
City Chiefs I'm sure that most of our
listeners who are going to be attending
will be Chiefs fans but I think we can
get away with talking about different
topics too and if you also if you want
to great meetup opportunity January 20th
and 22nd the best meetup of the year it
will be at draft picks and Mobile
Alabama you just wanted to hear the acts
I did I want to I get it now
best meetups that we do with stick to
football you have to come their draft
picks show up early I think we're gonna
have a crowd this year and then February
1st we will be in Florida for the
Superbowl that is in Miami I don't know
what we'll be doing for that one but
it's in Miami so it'll be fun
dressed casually prepared to drink
Connor you're gonna have the short
sleeve shirt on for sure right gotta
have it on Horrible's no other way all
day I need to start working out again
just getting ready for Florida it is
going to be wild all right let's jump
into the show like I said we're gonna
give you the updates you heard the
Wednesday morning show we got you
updated on a lot of the the players
declaring and not declaring for the
draft some coaching rumors and since
then John Dorsey has amicably
I guess broke up with the Cleveland
Browns maybe they fired him maybe they
didn't but this is interesting because
the Browns are now once again guys
pushing the reset button
the Haslam family Jimmy Haslam is set as
owners they're saying let's try this
another way and one thing that we've
heard for weeks
is that Paul DePodesta who if you're a
baseball fan
that name sounds familiar if you're a
movie fan Jonah Hill played this guy
basically in Moneyball
but Paul DePodesta is taking a be
controlling interest in this team how
the football structure is ran but guys I
think this is interesting
D Podesta does not live in Cleveland and
is not willing to live there full-time
so the the expectation around the league
is that he's not gonna become the
general manager but one thing that I've
seen folks reporting and something I've
even heard behind the scenes is that the
guys that he wanted them to hire were
like Shawn McDermott Kevin Stefanski
some of the guys who are that you know
best coaches of what they're doing in
the NFL right now but Dorsey or Sashi
Brown before him wouldn't pull the
trigger on those hires I think Josh
McDaniels a name to watch here I think
Kevin Stefanski is definitely a name to
watch we can see Andrew Barry get this
GM job with Paul DePodesta in a team
president type role but I think it's
notable Mel O'Connor because the Browns
again are resetting two years after they
hired John Dorsey and we all praise that
with Elliott Wolff and Alonzo Highsmith
it didn't work couldn't get it done
they're starting over I mean they bring
in a lot of stars under John Dorsey but
again kind of what you saw with him in
Kansas City there's not a lot of depth
to that team the offensive line is just
shot right now so it looks good on paper
when you bring in guys like Odell
Beckham Jarvis Landry had a good draft
with Nick Chubb able to pick him up
Baker Mayfield 1st overall but they need
somebody in there that can build some
depth and a real team not just you know
Madden building where you're just
pulling in the big name stars I don't
know who they go with next I think that
Cleveland is probably going to struggle
to fill both the head coaching job and
the GM job but we'll see not a lot of
people wanting to live in Cleveland I
know I don't but for the right amount of
money I'll live anywhere yeah I think
when you look at what went wrong here it
really is about you know not the first
15 to 20 players on the roster it was
what was behind them they did make a lot
of splash moves a lot of bold moves
we're gonna see how the Baker Mayfield
pick pans out you know you're one looks
really good year two did not look good
at all so that's a big question mark and
I think Odell Beckham this year did not
bring to the table what a lot of people
would hope for
still think Odell is a great player but
let's be real there's been a lot of
swings and misses from Dorsey but it
this is
probably more about the relationships in
the building and what went wrong and
when you look at deep Podesta I'm biased
I love him because he was the guy that
was in charge of scouting and player
development that got the Mets to a World
Series in 2015
everywhere this guy goes it seems like
there is some success with that now it
is he ready to run a football team or it
lead that kind of search that remains to
be seen but it is interesting that the
Browns
it felt like finally there was stability
and once again it's all gone and I'm
gonna lead right into the next nugget on
our rundown here when you're talking
about the the general mentioned the head
coach you have to wonder are you going
to be limited to people who believe in
Baker Mayfield he was the number one
pick in the 2018 and I fell draft so
whether it's Josh McDaniels or Kevin
Stefanski or Robert Sala whoever you're
bringing in and the same for the general
manager position does it have to be
someone who believes in Baker Mayfield
and I think Andrew Berry is interesting
because this is someone who is a pretty
good marriage internally of analytics
and scouting and I think we've talked
about this before the analytic community
loved Baker Mayfield and so with Andrew
berry you feel like okay maybe you're
getting a guy who is is going to be on
board with that someone who is with the
Eagles right now is the VP of football
operations so III think that that that
is interesting
will this be a situation where you're
basically mandated okay you will you
have to work with Baker Mayfield
everything we're doing right now is to
get him to where we saw him at times in
his rookie season and like you said l
didn't get the most out of him I think
injuries to blame for that but it's a
Brown's team I mean they lacked
discipline but also outside of Nick
Chubb no one lived up to expectations
Denzel Ward and greedy Williams can't
stay healthy miles Garrett gets
suspended Olivier Vernon didn't really
do much and no one David a joke who
apparently wants out of there completely
it's just a team that when we looked at
them before the year guys it was like
you know their offensive line was kind
of patchwork but they don't really have
a weakness now we look at them four
months later and it's like God all these
players will be expected to be great did
not take that next step and as we have
here
run down will Urban Meyer have interest
here there's been rumors that he's
feeling that coaching itch again he's
passed now all the college openings that
were there that would have intrigued him
so the NFL does make some sense we see
the Browns job open the Cowboys job may
be open I don't know what the [ __ ]
going on there
but is Urban Meyer to August 8 I'm not
opposed the question Urban Meyer is not
someone I would want to hire for the
head coach of the Cleveland Browns
you're probably not somebody I would
want to hire in the NFL either if I was
a athletic director my football job
opened up the Urban Meyer would probably
be one of the first guys I called if I
wanted to win a national championship
I just we've said it all week on stick
to football I don't know if what he does
best is gonna play in the NFL but the
Browns have a really strong interest in
him is what the report says so I think
that they're probably calling him
they're probably trying to get him to
interview for this job and I've also
seen reports that they want to hire the
head coach first and then try to pair a
general manager with the head coach I do
think that's the right direction to go I
just don't know the Urban Meyer is the
guy that I want to know hitch my wagon
to if you're hiring urban I think a
couple things have to be under
consideration one he's gonna be like the
de-facto GM he's gonna be one of those
head coaching hires where you're giving
him so much control to do things his way
his way to build a program I think
another thing is here if things don't go
right in the first year or two he'll
just walk away so it's not like that's
why we've seen it so many times where if
you go get a guy like Matt rule Lincoln
Riley now I know rule already denied the
Browns Lincoln right Lincoln Reilly's
not going to Cleveland those guys are in
it to build a program for the long haul
I think the risk would Obon is that
that's not there so he might be trying
to get one more big payday take a stab
at the NFL see B to have success there I
don't like that match at all and if
we're wrong we're wrong but I think the
Browns need to do things a little bit
you know kind of old school here and get
somebody that you believe in I know Josh
McDaniels name has been thrown out there
I don't know if he's going to Cleveland
though that that's another one that
seems like a big reach yeah and it's
funny guys because what we've said about
Cleveland all year was how this is a
team that lacks discipline they need
structure they need culture
you're gonna tell me Urban Meyer's the
guy you're gonna hire to instill culture
look at his Florida team we're like
almost everyone is now dead or in jail
like Tim Tebow right I don't think that
Urban Meyer's the guy that you really
are he's on top of my list of like let's
get someone to come in here and like
really you know hunker down and turn
this franchise around splashy higher but
when I'm not a huge fan of now as far as
the 2020 NFL Draft goes we've seen a lot
of interesting decisions as of late the
biggest one that we're waiting for
outside of some senior ball commitments
is what Alabama quarterback to a tongue
of Eylau will do and to has said on
Thursday Wednesday night excuse me that
he wouldn't announce his decision on
Monday January 6 so I know what we're
gonna be talking about on the Tuesday
morning edition of stick to football it
will be to his decision and I'm excited
to see what he what he does and I'll be
upfront and honest with our listeners
and our viewers I don't know
generally I have pretty good feel for
what players are doing with - I've heard
it both ways
as of Thursday afternoon at 4:40 p.m.
Central time I'll tell you the latest
I've heard is that he's leaning toward
going back but a lot can change in the
next four or five days yeah I I actually
get the vibe - I haven't heard anything
I don't know of any reports but I get
the vibe that this is a guy that wants
to return to Alabama it seems like he
really likes college football I think
that he could be the first domino to
fall I mean Alabama tweeted it out not
too long ago that the dominoes falling I
think that he could return I think that
they're looking at probably a pretty big
insurance policy like the [ __ ] show we
saw with Dillon Moses on Thursday I
think they could be looking to insure
him for a significant amount of money
he's probably I mean Nick Saban kind of
talked about how he got a top 15 draft
grade so he's gonna be able to do that
and whatever that is yeah right so I
think that they're looking at that and
probably have already figured it out he
has a doctor's appointment today two of
us as we're talking to make sure
everything's good with the hip I think
that he's probably gonna get good news
from that doctor's appointment and on
Monday he's probably gonna announce that
he's going back to Alabama I will say
with those insurance policies I know
we talk about them and we have to talk
about him and you mentioned the Dylan
Moses situation which have you missed it
don't Moses said he was going back to
Alabama and then apparently his father
who's a lawyer on Thursday hacked
Dylan's Instagram account BAE the Lord
of London you're the cheese that his
majesty Dylan Moses and they put out
this statement that's really weird and
just says that really the Dylan doesn't
have the ability to make his decision on
his own whether he's going to the NFL or
not and that they were evaluating
everything but these insurance policies
listen is like Vegas
there's a reason reason they're building
these massive casinos because they
usually win it's the same with these
insurance policies Jaylon Smith who is
the most clear-cut example of a player
falling in the draft because of entry
had a hard time getting his entry payout
from the insurance company so I wouldn't
just look at it and say like Oh done
Moses hurt his knee he's gonna fall in
the draft and he's gonna get his payout
it's not that simple I think it's very
hard to prove that that was the sole
reason you fell in the trap so with two
uh yeah he's gonna have a policy whether
it's this year I'm sure he had one he
would have a big one next year but I
think those things are just very paid
for the school is allowed to pay your
premium yes how is that not an NCAA
violation yeah that's really bizarre
because you can see EE once these guys
come back to school so they're allowing
for that to happen but Connor if you're
too if you're Dylan Moses where's your
head out on this I get the [ __ ] out is
what I do I go to the NFL I don't even
think this is like I can't believe it's
come down to this to be honest with you
Dylan Moses here's the thing he didn't
play this year he probably would have
been a first-round pick I think it said
he got a second round back I understand
it a little more if he goes back to
school because the guy's a great player
and he could show teams you know that I
am a great college player and solidify
himself as this top 15 top 10 pick for
the following year in the draft
hopefully go win a national title
Alabama get a couple awards I understand
all of that
tua it does is not granted the luxury
where he's gonna step on the field next
year and he's gonna submit himself as a
top five pick he's gonna be joining a
draft class with Trevor Lawrence and
Justin fields how can he step on a
college field again and risk injury
again I don't understand this at all
you're gonna be a first-round pick this
year whether that is in the top 10 or
whether that's in the top 20
it's millions and millions of dollars he
cannot pass that up go into the draft if
you have to do your rehab with an NFL
team that's great it's an NFL team
they're gonna invest in you they're not
gonna rush you back on the field you're
gonna make millions of dollars I just I
can't even fathom two of going back to
school I think it's best for you and I
don't like speaking for what's best for
other people the people that are not me
but on the outside looking in I can not
even fathom twoa going back for another
year in college football playing for
free yeah in Nick Saban died I think
some of the best that his recruiting
some of the best recruiting we've seen
him do is internally Alex Leatherwood is
going back so you got your left half so
he doesn't need to I agree but like
Raekwon Davis last year you know these
are guys who could probably a
second-round pick but instead they're
going back to Alabama to try to improve
their stock so I think he's done a good
job one surprise guys Cole commits the
tight end from Notre Dame
back in November posted on in social
media that he was coming back to Notre
Dame he was gonna play baseball and so
we all deleted him off our big boards
well Thursday Cole commits declared for
the NFL Draft so out of nowhere I don't
thinks a lot left field for your
baseball analogy he is my top rated
Titan in this class when we get into our
top 32 big boards you'll see just how
highly I have him rated but guys I think
Cole commits is exactly what the New
England Patriots need he's what the
Green Bay Packers need those teams at
the end of round one who have a big
tight in need are gonna be all over this
guy yeah I agree and I did delete him as
well off my big board had to go in and
patch him back in there today so I
haven't watched a lot of tape on him
I've been trying to watch some of these
other guys and look at the tide in class
even specifically but he hasn't been on
there so he's gonna make my top 32 but I
haven't done a lot of work on him yet
I'm excited to watch more cuz whenever I
watched this football team this guy
stands out he is a round one tight end
for me and he's somebody that this tight
end class really needed let's be real I
mean the one guy I was excited about is
hunter Brian and he's a chess piece kind
of player he's not this inline gonna
block tight end he's an athlete he's
around too kind of athlete at the
position so I think this is a great
addition for this trap
glass and and I'm really excited to see
him go through the process now I thought
that was the last nugget guys but I just
saw on Twitter get ready for this Ohio
State's punter has announced he's going
back here that he's awesome check out
his Twitter he's great yeah drew
Chrisman he does like bottle flips
except for he's a punter so he kicks all
of them I mean I followed him today it's
some pretty cool stuff that he's doing
so I'm excited that he was going back to
Ohio State it's too bad that he can't
have a YouTube channel and make some
money off of write hit his Twitter is
fantastic why flip it when you can kick
it he's great he'll be back flipping the
field for the Buckeyes next year let's
take a break when we come back our top
32 big boards we are back in we're gonna
break down the big boards it's time for
all three of us to unveil our big board
so if you guys saw and the bleach report
out this week I put out a mock draft and
my big board but assets that time of
year well always updating these things
as we were sitting down this evening I
was complaining about how like god I
gotta move that guy up he's too low and
it's just it's that time when you start
putting grades on players when we start
getting a full look at the class with
guys declaring and announcing they're
going back to school we're getting a
very full picture of the 2020 class and
I am up first to give you one through 16
is that right or 32 to 17 I don't care
okay I'm gonna 32 to 17 I like to work
backward so I want to I want to cheat I
feel like I can do this I want to say 34
players because I could not feel here's
the reason I for okay I have KJ hammer
at 33 and I have Zack bond 32
those are three of my favorite players
in the entire class and I couldn't like
I couldn't split the tie to get them all
in so there's 34 to 32 all right 31
Ashton Davis safety from Cal number 30
Cole commits Titan from Notre Dame 29
Savior McKinney safety from Alabama 28
Kayla van chase on edge from LSU 27
Justin Herbert quarterback from Oregon
26 you door grows meadows edge from Penn
State 25 Devon to Smith wide receiver
Alabama who might go back to school
number
24:00 ylvis' casino wide reciever
Colorado 23 Christian Fulton corner LSU
and a little secret here I have three
corners tied you guys know I do this I'm
waiting for the tiebreaker as we get
into the process so I have CJ Henderson
Paulson and debo and Christian Fulton
tied so 21 22 23 number 20 Terrell Lewis
edge from Alabama number 19 DeAndre
Swift running back Georgia number 18 JK
Dobbins running back Ohio State and
number 17 my last one here Kenneth
Murray linebacker from Oklahoma now the
way this works is Melo at Conner now get
to rip apart my board I talked me into
Justin Herbert because I have him much
same I did he didn't make mine I don't
feel like he's a first-round court he's
going to be drafted in the first round
right probably six overall but what do
you see from him that puts him in your
top 30 - I have a hard time with Justin
Herbert because I feel like it's you can
watch him play like the Rose Bowl there
are throws and there are plays that he
makes with his feet where I'm like
goddamn that's the number one
quarterback like that's that is a
franchise quarterback then there are
plays like the screen pass where I want
to punch him through the TV so it's hard
for me and I admit there are a lot of
plays with him where he misses wide open
throws he doesn't get to his second or
third progression I think my hope with
Justin Herbert is that he can be like a
Josh Allen where you can get him in the
NFL and if you put him in a system that
will take advantage of his strengths he
can be good serviceable even and so I
think with his size his athleticism his
arm strength what he can do in the
pocket breaks down if you surround him
with some weapons and I think if there's
a knock to Oregon's offense great
offensive line and I like CJ Verdell the
receivers were not very good a lot of
drop passes
Justin Herbert doesn't turn the ball
over I think that's one plus to his game
he's just got to be a little bit quicker
as a processor but you know what those
are a lot of the things I said about
Carson Wentz and I don't think that
Justin Herbert is there from a
leadership standpoint but I don't know
that we should knock his toughness I
think it's just kind of odd dude so for
me the traits are good enough that I
wouldn't draft him at 6 or 7 overall so
I was gonna I probably wouldn't draft
him if I'm the Colts maybe you'd think
about it like I think middle around 1
but what if you're sitting there at
Tampa Bay though I mean yeah what's that
15
14:14 f4 it's a uh I wouldn't feel great
about it cuz that's your job if you take
a quarterback in the first round at your
job where I haven't like 27 if the
Patriots drafted this guy to be that the
next you know quarterback there that's
one thing you know or the saying the
Saints did that's another thing I'm not
investing a top 10 pick in this dude
though I like on the flip a lot of Colts
fans have been talking about
quarterbacks they have the second pick
in the second round I think that is
where they probably use that pick to get
a quarterback I don't think Justin
Herbert will be there but that also kind
of pushes these guys down because I
don't think that the Colts are team
that's gonna be targeting a quarterback
in the first round Tampa Bay might
actually bring back Jameis Winston I
think after you get through 6 & 7 we're
probably gonna see no more quarterbacks
until you're talking about teams like
you know maybe the Saints at the back
end of it or the you know the Patriots
but I agree with that when Connor was
there anybody that you wanted to give
him at hell for now Herbert was the big
one because I just looked at my board
and saw you know who was the noticeable
one and quarterbacks are always gonna be
that guy
he didn't make my top 32 and I think
he'll be in a lot of top thirty twos and
I could I get why there will be a team
that I'll try to take him as a franchise
quarterback but he just seems like a day
to player to me anyone you thought I was
too low on no I don't think so I'm sorry
if I missed it did Donovan peoples Jones
make that cut he did not I'll say I have
dpj at forty seven overall okay yeah
because spoiler alert he'll be 32 for me
and he's the player I'm the most torn on
because the upside is gigantic and he
just they couldn't get him the ball the
way they should have at that program
yeah tough tough eval and the receivers
for me I've been asked a lot about the
receivers in this class and it's like I
love to talk about one specific I don't
want to talk about one specific one but
like KJ Hamlin Justin Jefferson or Gabe
Davis like I really liked those guys and
in a traditional draft class they're
round 1 players for me this receiver
class is insane 28 receivers were
drafted last year 35 is the highest
since 2015 at some point you have to say
like okay how many guys are gonna get
drafted and and how many you're going to
get draft
in each round so mellow you're up 32 to
70 I'll go 32 to 17 and I will tell you
guys I [ __ ] love the runningback
class so there's a lot of them four of
them gonna make my list here but I'm
gonna start with number 32 overall for
me and that's Tyler by - Center out of
Wisconsin he's trending down I will say
that but I feel like he's a safe pick
when you get into the later into the
first round you're looking at teams that
probably need some interior offensive
linemen like the 49ers specifically or
the Chiefs even could go with interior
offensive line and he's gonna be sitting
there as the number one graded center in
this class he's 32 for me
Najee harris running back for is sitting
at 31 overall Cole commit that time in
right back for ya okay
buckle up I told you Cole commit number
30 overall the tight end from Notre Dame
eater gross Meadows edge out of Penn
State is it 29 28 clay Vaughn chase on
and that's where I have a tie between
those two guys on my list
number 27 Xavier McKinney safety out of
Alabama number 26
I also like them receivers ylvis' Cochet
knelt he isn't a wide receiver number
six I might need to double check those
numbers for me buddy wide receiver out
of Colorado really liked his athletic
ability number 25 Tristan worst tackle
out of Iowa 24 pulse in a debo corner
out of Stanford 23 AJ epinet
out of Iowa number 22 another receiver
Justin Jefferson I see you typing over
there wide receiver out of LSU I really
like his game number 21 JK Dobbins
running back Ohio State 20
Travis etn running back Clemson I have
those two guys tied right now I really
like both of their games they're very
different but I like both of them number
19 overall Andrew Thomas tackle out of
Georgia running back to Matt I love him
I know you do too Jonathan Taylor out of
Wisconsin and number 17 overall
Christian Fulton corner out of Ellis oh
boy am I ready for this okay I think
that you were too high on Jonathan
Taylor and I think you're too high on
Travis Eaton Jonathan Taylor had over
900 carries in three years in college
and he fumbled 18 times
and nine hundred carry I know that the
carry number is high that's a lot of
wear and tear and the fumble number is
high now I I do like Jonathan Taylor I
want to say that I like him I think he
deserves credit for how much he got
better as a pass receiver this year but
that's just more touches like he had a
like 976 touches in college that's a
concern for me with Travis etn I
compared him to Chris Johnson Travis he
Tina's a guy I could end up being way
too low on even though I have around to
grade on him because I feel like he is
incredibly scheme specific now if he
gets in the right scheme were there like
we just want a home run hitter with
speed at the position Travis he Tian's
great for that but he is not a very big
guy and there is not a lot of pop to his
game so I I do I've Nagi Harris ranked
above both of those running backs after
a little bit of shuffling as of late and
I have JK Dobbins as the number one back
in this class really I think the thing
that jumped out to me is you're you're
definitely a little lower on Tristan
Dwarfs and Andrew Thomas than the
consensus yeah I'm not in love with the
tackle class I think that both of those
guys could come in a right tackle but I
think we're kind of making the left
tackles more than what they are I need
to look at him where I like both Andrew
Thomas I think he comes in he probably
starts as a rookie but I don't know that
he's that top-tier tackle that you want
reminds me of the guy the Redskins took
a while back Brandon Scherff Oprah and
he ended up playing guard like God you
know that out of Iowa with Tristan works
like I see him pull from tackle my holy
[ __ ] maybe this guy can move but then I
also see him get beat to hell by gross
Meadows from Penn State and I think
maybe this guy's not the marquee tackle
that everybody wants him to be yeah I
don't think that's crazy at all I look
at wharfs and I think he he has a guards
body and style of play and I want to
call both of those guys are too gnarly
honestly yeah
which is that's all for a tackle yeah
yeah I want to defend my running backs
too I don't know the a either of those
guys Jonathan Taylor or Travis Eaton I
don't think they get drafted in the
first round but I think we will look
back at this draft and say how the hell
did we let these two running backs fall
to the second round like I get it as a
guy who watches the draft and talks to
that you probably don't want to take
them in the first round but I think both
of them come come in and be very
productive the touches are concerned
because 900 in college is a lot but you
know look at Zeke Elia Le'Veon Bell
Christian McCaffrey even had a lot of
touches in Stanford Derrick Henry at
Alabama you Nick Chubb had a lot of
carries coming out of Georgia and he
also destroyed his knee he also led the
AFC and rushing I believe so I mean yeah
so I the touches are concerned but is
there anything to back it up that says
you know what these guys are already
worn down like give me his first
contract give me four years with
Jonathan Taylor and then I'll cut him
free like people should have done you
know with Zeke or some of these other
backs I will say and I want to bring up
one other play on your board for me with
a running back you're gonna draft me in
the first round they have to be a to
contract player and I know there's an
argument right now that you never give a
running back a second contract which
which means maybe you don't draft him in
the first round but like I can't build
around a player in the first round for
four years right so and then one other
guy you are a lot lower than me on a
japanesse and I know we've talked about
him a little bit he's your thing that
he's just too much of a tweener because
he's kind of an edge he's kind of a you
know a 66 to 80 he might have to play
interior d-line yeah trying to figure
out what is he because he's listed at an
edge but he's six six you know 280
reminds me a lot of Solomon Thomas and
rashon Gary it's like where the hell do
you have these two guys where can he be
most effective can he come into the NFL
and play for 10 years somewhere along
the defensive line yeah but you talk
about second contract guys see a second
contract guy so you got to be that guy
that can come in and get you 10 sacks or
is he gonna be a guy that can come in
play pretty well against the run and get
you maybe six sacks a year I think that
that is his floor I do have him
obviously ranked fairly high in my top
32 he's 23 overall I just don't know if
there's that star potential that comes
in where he's a marquee edge rusher
she's been so good the last two years
yeah you you wonder if the flashes will
convert to consistency which is the
biggest question with all the pass
rushers in this class not named chase
young not really so all right I'm gonna
let it rip 32 Donovan peoples Jones
talked about him earlier this is a
potential pick a ceiling pick a deep
wide receiver
class he's gonna test very well and I
think he'll jump up boards after that 31
Trey Smith still waiting to see if he
declares he might you might have that
news when you're listening to this show
cuz he said it'll come down to after the
bowl game he's a round one player with
debatable medicals that's gonna be the
big thing for Trey Smith but he is
really really impressive on film 30k
LaVon chase on listen when you look at
what chase Anand has done in some big
moments he's at rate sky as a pass
rusher he really is I think the
inconsistencies have me I mean before
the season we were talking about this
guy's a top 15 player now he's sitting
here at 30 so you know just got to put
it put it more consistently together but
pass rushers they always get drafted
high 29 in LaVista Chennault we talk
about him every week you know what he is
28 Travis etn I love etn speed his
acceleration is absolutely insane
Matt made a good point that you know
scheme will matter for him but if he
falls into the right scheme this guy is
a fourteen hundred yard kind of player
he really is now especially now that
he's catching the ball as well 27th ray
Adams from Washington another big
medicals guy on the offensive line but I
love what I've seen from him at
offensive tackle and he's a mammoth you
don't have to worry about length or
height with this guy 26 Tyler be it ish
I think he's been okay this year but I
think he's also been battling injuries
and I still think he's the top center in
this class 25 Cole commits top tight end
it's really no dispute right now for me
24 Jake a Dobbins love what he's done
this year absolutely great bounce-back
year and he is a day one plug and play
running back 23 here Kenneth Murray
incredible speed for the linebacker
position 22 Jonathan Taylor I'm a big
fan I think he's going to be very
effective at the next level the guy
could do it all and the wear and tear is
not a gigantic concern for me 21 t
Higgins and go up and get the football
kind of wide receiver he'll help some
quarterback at the next level I think
he's a great fit for the bills we put
him there on mock draft Monday a couple
of times 20 Javon Kinlaw a great year
for him he's gonna go down to the Senior
Bowl and wreck people 19 Grant Delpit a
little bit of a fall for grants out but
had him in the top five to start the
season he hasn't made a lot of plays but
I still think he could be really
effective at the next level 18 Dylan
Moses the lord of one
we don't know if he's declaring or not
I'm not gonna take him off the board
until we get this official news yet for
Dylan Moses but he's in the top 20 if he
does end up coming out 17 Justin
Jefferson you know kind of came on for
under my eyes late he has had in a
remarkable season and has been one of my
biggest risers on this board so that's
it guys I mean a lot of wide receivers a
lot of running backs that's where the
meat and potatoes of this class really
is the two that I'll say that I'm most
different on you are the tres Adams and
Smith and I know like you said they're
both big medical guys I feel so badly
for Trey Adams because I can remember
three years ago it was like this is
going to be a first round offensive
tackle and then he has the back injury
I've watched him this year and just feel
like he can't move anymore and I I'm
very excited to see him in mobile
because you can't hide anything down
there week when you get one-on-ones and
we get in those past rush drills you
can't hide anything you don't have help
I actually I really think the offensive
lines actually kind of set up to fail
and a lot of those drills but that's
good because I want to see if he can
move any more with Trey Smith the blood
clots are concerned we're gonna pretend
to be a doctor but that is is it scary
for me I also wonder about conditioning
because he is a mammoth person and like
we've you know we've talked about
individually about and I just had a
brain fart about meki Becton from
Louisville but it's like sometimes guys
are too big and I wonder if Trey Smith
is gonna be a conditioning question yeah
and those are the two guys that I had a
question about - Matt you pretty much
said it all I do want to see what they
can do come Senior Bowl time I think
that the edge class isn't real sexy but
you have guys like Bradley and I and
Terrell Lewis who are supposed to be at
the Senior Bowl hopefully they don't
drop out I think those could be some
good matchups hopefully we can see them
on the same teams or at least see him go
up against one of those guys he should
be in the north so hopefully that puts
him with Bradley and I think that's a
very good matchup to look forward to at
the Senior Bowl yeah and on the other
side Connor T hey guns is the one that I
am probably higher on the new and we'll
get into that after our break when we
get into my top 16 but what have you not
seen from him that you want to see or
what
keeps him down on your board I'm really
curious to see how he runs number one
because when he wins on these 50 and 60
yard bombs a lot of the times I've seen
some coverage lapses or just really poor
defense where I'm not saying he's slow
cuz I don't think he's slow
I just don't know and then I also wonder
when you're in that offense you know do
sometimes they take away Justin Ross or
are they worried about Travis etn these
are things that I personally just need
to catch up on and I think when I watch
Higgins on broadcast he looks like a top
25 player when I watch it more of the
all 22 he might look like a top 15
player those are the little nitpicky
things and I think that's why boards are
so fluid if Troy Adams goes down to
mobile and we're 10 feet away from the
one-on-ones and he can't move side to
side he falls to the second or third
round for me it's as simple as that so
these are the things that I'm really
excited to dive into in the months of
January February and March that I just
don't know where I'm at right now all
right let's take a break we come back
top 16 such a bit lights on top 16 from
all three of us uptick PA and me believe
I got my chance this is great all right
it is time get out your pen and paper
write this stuff down
top 16 players from all three of us I
will kick this off number 16 Tristan
wharfs offensive tackle from Iowa 15
grant Delpit safety from LSU number 14
Andrew Thomas offensive tackle from
Georgia 13 Javon Kinlaw defensive
lineman from South Carolina 12 t Higgins
wide receiver Clemson 11 Henry rugs wide
receiver Alabama 10 AJ epinet defensive
end from Iowa 9 CD Lam wide receiver
Oklahoma 8 Jedrek wills offensive tackle
from Alabama my number 1 offensive
tackle in this class 7 to attack of Iowa
quarterback Alabama 6 Derrick brown
defensive lineman from Auburn my top
interior defensive lineman 5 Isaiah
Simmons linebacker from Clemson for Jeff
Okuda Corner Ohio State 3 Jerry Judy
wide receiver Alabama 2 and really it's
like 1b joe burrow quarterback LSU and
number 1a chase young edge rusher Ohio
State I feel like that's
cookie cutter yeah a lot of those guys I
agree with won the top five or six is
like a right guy that I have that I'm
higher on the newest CD lamb I don't
remember why I have nine III having met
six I'll go ahead and I say that do you
think that he is getting close to that
wide receiver one or at least where we
can consider a 1 a 1 B I know that I
have them right there at five and six I
don't have them tied like I have with
other positions I still have Judy ahead
of him but how close are you with Judy
and lamb I I can't I can't put lamb at
number one every time I watch Judy it's
like I want to video it and send it to
people and be like this is what receiver
should look like you know outside of
being Julio Jones the bursts the
footwork how just everything is so clean
and then he will I body catch one or two
is cooked against Michigan right it's
just like he's so beautiful in terms of
his footwork his birth this agility his
balance his body control and I like CD
lamb a lot I think my biggest concern CD
lambs toughness is my favorite thing
about him and how he he plays so much
bigger than he is but I feel like the
Oklahoma scheme has limited his route
tree I don't like have you ever seen CD
lamb beat someone like with speed it's
either he's wide open over the middle or
or he's contested over the middle really
so I think the scheme is a question mark
for me because we know he's not gonna
run well and so if there's with every
player we could play the game of if they
bust it will be because with CD lamb if
he bust it will be because he's not fast
enough to separate and he needs to get
into you know he needs to go to the New
Orleans Saints where he can run slants
you know like Michael Thomas where
Mike's not the fastest guy but he's a
great route runner so he's okay he can
he can eat in that offense with CD I
worry that he'll get somewhere like
Oakland where they're gonna say well we
need you to stretch the field and he's
like [ __ ] I can't do that yeah I can see
that he just looks so dangerous and he's
able to get open it could be scheme fit
but to be able to get open without the
speed I also worry is he just beating
the [ __ ] out of big 12 corners
because there are not a lot of those
guys on my big board so I do have some
questions they were CD lame I think he's
one of those guys where he's always open
you know five feet above his head it
feels like that with him where when he's
not open
he still catches the ball whether it's
snatching it away whether it's
side-to-side over his head I'm with you
I understand why let's just call it what
it is
I think CD lambs running a four or five
five yep I think that'd be a good day
for him
yep yeah I mean he's like a four six
five guy out of high school so you
assume with a little training you could
shave that down to a four five five I
want people to know this now so the
reactions are he falls out of the top 5
to the 2nd round many people's heads
when it happens cuz it's gonna happen
yep I mean it was that with Michael
Thomas we tried to condition people he's
not gonna run in the four fours and for
me it didn't matter he was still my top
receiver in that class but it's like you
need to have an expectation anyone else
you want to roast me but I had one a
question for you Matt cuz I left him off
this but he'll be in my top 16 if he
does declare there's a lot of rumors
he's not where did you have Devon to
Smith I had him I had him in the second
half actually so I had him at 25 overall
okay yeah so Hopey in my top 32 if he
declares it's just nobody there's been
so much smoke around him staying I don't
know why right I have him at 37 overall
I can drugs there's been a lot of buzz
that they might stay and I had rugs I
think I'm a I think I'm high on drugs
than either of you I've met eleven
overall I'm at 14 okay never mind then I
think Robert law so yeah but there's
been a lot of lot above there I'm glad
that I can do a top 16 you guys honestly
Matt you were reading it and it was
almost like I was looking at like we
were very close as we'll see very very
close we spend a lot of time together
yes all right I'll read mine off next
let's see who you guys just mellow
number 16 overall go ahead write it down
CJ Henderson Reuters former Florida I
still love him and I don't think if he
can talk me out of it number 15 Javon
Kinlaw number 14 grant Delpit 13 Kenneth
Murray 12 DeAndre Swift I think he's
gonna be a special running back 11 Henry
rugs 10t higgins 9 Jedrek wills 8 - uh
assuming he comes out seven Derrick
brown six-cd Lam five Jerry Judy for
Isaiah Simmons three Jeff CUDA to burrow
one chase young I don't really have
anything the one for me see Andre Swift
and uh I've cooled on him and I think I
I'll be just transparent some of that is
he's had a bad into the year and so
there might be a recency bias of I
really like how JK Dobbins is playing I
really like hanashi Harris is playing it
was Swift you got a guy who's not the
biggest dude in the world and he's got
the shoulder injury and he just hasn't
been as much of an impact you know SEC
championship game the game against why
did my brain just stopped working the
game against Baylor so it's just I think
I'm a little down on him because of what
we've seen as of late and it isn't what
have you done for me lately League and
so by the time we get to April I could
get back I mean I've John Dre's my
number two running back and he's number
19 overall so it's not like you know you
don't like him right I'm just I have
questions I guess yeah the way he puts
his foot in the ground and changes
directions and his ability to catch the
ball out of the backfield what makes
them I popped them to Alvin Kamara I do
like right I think he's like a poor
man's sake one I think he's great I mean
I I see the flashes that McCaffrey had
mmm Russ yeah with Swift so alright let
it rip then I want to ask real quick
Connor you know since we don't have a
lot of differences in these what like
how clear-cut is Joe borough is
quarterback one for you I guess that's
how a phrase that question he's not I'm
not a solid on him as you are I'm saying
about him being 1a 1b it does concern me
the talent that he has at receiver and
the fact that it was a one-year thing
now Connor and I mentioned it on Monday
this is the best season I think we've
ever seen a college football quarterback
half so he has that going for him but
how much of it is scheme with Joe Brady
with the receivers the running backs
offensive line like everything was in
place
for a fifth-year guy to come in I think
his floor is very high I think at you're
at least getting a very good quarterback
that can come in and win to you some
games I don't know if you're getting a
Pro Bowl quarterback hey he could be
Andy Dalton I think that's his floor so
that kind of concerns me when I look at
to uh
if he's healthy and when he's healthy he
looks like a special quarterback not
just because he's throwing up huge
numbers to a great wide receiver core
but his ability to throw the ball
accurately if you can get him in better
condition you can get him stronger and
healthier I think that he's one of the
best quarterbacks we've ever seen listen
my take is to it is the most talented
quarterback in this class that's it
light and I have burrow ahead of him a
little bit as you'll hear but I'd if I
hear two is healthy and ready to go I'm
it's gonna be a long couple months from
me sitting there staring at it I love
Joe burrow he's great he's phenomenal I
just I think too it can be special and
this is makes this debate between them
such a headache is kind of rip nobody
all right 16h AJ epinet infilling 14
Henry rugs 13 Tristan worse he's a guy
that can you know go up or down we'll
see how measurements and things go
another guy that could go way up or way
down 12 feet or gross tomatoes super
high ceiling pass rusher 11 DeAndre
swift 10 Isaiah Simmons 9 Jedrek wills 8
Andrew Thomas 7 to a tongue of Aloha 6
Derek brown 5 Joe burrow for Jerry Judy
3 CD lamb to Geoff Okuda 1 chase young
that is the highest I've heard Stevie
lamb ranked and I don't consume a lot of
Draft contents maybe I'm not the best
guy to ask but that is that seems really
high for Stevie lamb yeah it's up there
I mean him and Judy I'm stacking them
because I'm a coward 3 & 4 I don't
believe oh that's really high on gross
tomatoes and I was gonna point out you
liked Derek or you like Brian burns last
year more than I think definitely more
than I did more than engine more the
both of us do you feel like you're
starting to develop a type like I have a
type your receiver everyone knows it do
you think you're getting a time or not
mister type for everything I have a type
for every night array from
yeah I think so I think what gross
Tomatoes when I do like a full film
evaluation I'll learn the little things
like with burns and went the opposite
way
I had him sitting at like 20 for four
months and then I watched him and then
he gained the weight at the combine and
I'm like no he's put everything together
perfectly
I want to see gross Tomatoes do the same
thing like if he tests poorly that would
have a huge impact on my evil but I
don't think he will and I think he
already has the weight on him so yeah I
agree
I definitely think with pass rushers I
like the bursty athletic bendy kind of
guys it was the same with Carl Lawson
for a while he was a little you know
tighter built more compact but he was a
guy that could turn the corner and was
explosive
yeah whatever injuries but are they yeah
yeah so those are the two for me
they're probably stand out the most I
think the one player that you and I are
most different honest Isiah Simmons
maybe that's because I'm leading the fan
club but you had him at 10 I have him at
4 yeah I think he's great I really do I
think and I can't even sit here and tell
you well he's a linebacker that's why
he's at 10th because he's he's every
position so I'm I guess my fear with
Simmons is we have seen so many bonehead
defensive coaches misuse players over
the years with that our Swiss Army
knives that I'm almost like well I hope
he doesn't go somewhere with an idiot
staff because they'll waste away what
can be an exceptionally game-changing
player yep yeah I I think with Simmons
like you were saying you're making
Fitzpatrick with the Dolphins was like
hey they're all [ __ ] Pro yeah that's
like so with Isaiah Simmons I I
definitely agree that I worry that God
please let him go to the right system
but I think you could say that about
there are very few players in this class
that are just I think like system
breakers you almost redo our big boards
after we see where they're do I say that
every year it's because guys are gonna
move up based on though they're fit like
DK Metcalfe I had him late first when I
saw that dudeman Seattle I like can I
put him at 20 now like can I move him up
yeah she could run around come back to
the ball with a quarterback that gets
out of the pocket I totally get it
another thing guys that I want to make
clear with this class there are plenty
of really good football players in this
class
I think this thing dips the [ __ ] off
like kind of early yep like if you're
sitting there at like 18 you might be
like uh okay I'm just gonna take one of
the receivers now because I don't want
to take a a ver Agyei in the top 20 let
me take a corner you know cuz like okay
well you can always use corners mellow
and I've talked a lot about this the
edge rusher depth is really bad in this
class it's horrific it makes me wonder
if guys like to a Lewis gross may doze
Zach bond Kayla Vaughn chase on if
they're gonna float up the board because
the edge depth is really bad and I
wonder if receivers will push down
because of that of like okay I'll wait
in draft cuz like what's the difference
when Justin Jefferson and Devon to Smith
like you know I think there could be a
debate on which of those guys you'd
rather have I think even you could go
top in of that I mean how much different
RT Higgins in Justin Jefferson III have
them rated pretty differently but yeah I
think you're right we could see them
kind of float down the board because
they're so [ __ ] many ways like low
viscous Shane Hall and Brandon Iook like
I have like a 20 spot difference on
those two guys oh there's that
difference yeah I would agree with
here's the other kicker who's gonna come
out and free agency and give Shaq
Barrett 20 million dollars a year the
bucket because there's their sympathy I
mean right right sitting there and
they're going well we're not getting a
pass rusher in this draft so let's pay
the guy we got yeah I mean I don't have
sex right yeah there's a there's a bunch
of guys in the NFL that are probably
gonna be on contract years that are pass
rushers and guess what I wish I was
their agent right now
she'll Quietus nineteen and a half sacks
ever the Miami Dolphins should pay him
honest that's what I was just like South
just in the nude don't even have to
worry about will chase on will gross
meadows be available at 18 yeah and no
state income tax in Florida right and
he's already in for you know nicer
Florida those are our big boards let us
know what you think tweet at us
Astrix football leave it in your Apple
podcast review we love to see those
things take a break we'll close this out
with some draft on draft we are back and
it is draft on draft time and like
mellow so at the top of the show come to
our meet up so if you want to experience
draft on draft to the full come to a
meet-up char bar in Kansas City this
weekend the Senior Bowl the combine is
Super Bowl
because draft on draft especially the
Senior Bowl gets a little wild and by
the way if you're a regular listener and
you're wondering when the stickies are
happening we're working on it okay we're
getting there I'm trying to find some
trophies to order all right Pat
Chamberlain who is probably gonna get
one of those trophies ask the calendar
has turned to 2020 and everyone is doing
best of the decade sports list so I have
to ask what is the single best draft
class Oh decade in terms of the NFL
talent it produced I read this question
wrong first
so my answer by 2017 Saints but that's
not what he wants like by complete yeah
so I have my mind ready so if you guys
need to come up right off the top of my
head it's 2011 it is that's what I draft
you look at at Cam Newton number one
overall I know that he hasn't been
playing that well as of late but this
guy that took his team to the Super Bowl
on an MEP played very well and then Von
Miller number two overall Marcel Darius
who [ __ ] him Alabama but has had a
pretty good NFL career followed by AJ
Green Patrick Peterson said and Julio
Jones like those three guys I don't know
how AJ Green ended up getting drafted
ahead of Julio Jones but Pat Pete Julio
Jones like as of like a year ago those
are two of the best at their position
still and this is from the 2011 draft
there might be six Hall of Famers in the
top 11 Von Miller yep I think I don't
think AJ greenness Pat Peters Julio is
ty Ron Smith is and JJ Watt is ng that's
five Hall of Famers in the top 11
selections [ __ ] Mike pounds he might be
a Hall of Fame I think he's at 15 even a
guy like AJ Green might be able to get
in because he's a good dude and he
hasn't caused any problems it has been a
very good receiver so I think that he's
a guy that could sneak in Mike Pouncy
Ryan Kerrigan has been a good edge
rusher
Cam Hayward yeah Jordan I mean a solder
has been solid my favorite thing about
this class too is some of the gems like
Justin Houston went in the third round
Richard sheriff Richard Sherman went in
the fifth round Richard Sherman
in this class like Jason Kelsey in the
sixth round and then you look at they're
not in the draft class unfortunately but
Chris Harris jr. was a you DFA from this
group Doug Baldwin was a you DFA from
this group it's crazy how talented that
year was this was my first year 2011 was
my first year covering the draft for
bleacher report holy [ __ ] I was I mean
and bleacher report did - they were like
we have a Heisman Trophy winner a Cam
Newton we have a look at all these
receivers and like this is gonna be and
this this probably really helped launch
my career how good this draft was but
one of my all-time draft misses happened
in 2011 I don't know if you guys are
aware of this even I had Andy Dalton
rated ahead of Cam Newton I was not sure
that Cam Newton has a one-year starter
at Auburn would transition to the NS a
lot of character concerns a lot of
concern so I had Andy Dalton this QB one
Cam Newton is QB - so I'll tell you the
worst draft in the history of the NFL
Draft is the 2014 draft so bad they're
gone 13 13 13 13 yeah Eric Fisher number
one overall yeah that's all Bible Luke
jokl and dion jordan that seems team
Milner in that I drank so much
yeah yeah he was oh yeah New York jazz
like oh let's watch the I mean that that
was the worst senior bullets really
Alabama players get drafted in a row D
Miller chance for Mack and DJ Flutie on
George oh no it was bad it was a badger
I mean when thinking ah this is the
number five picking your draft got Lane
Johnson might be the only good player
from this draft no I liked it Picaro was
pretty good Eric weed but I mean those
are the top of the drab Travis Frederick
Zach Ertz in the second round maybe but
like that's levy on bail in the second
round I didn't love him out of Michigan
State though it was bad yeah speaking of
fire Eddie Lacy 245 strapped we did this
draft at a bowling alley that Boomer
Esiason owns in midtown Manhattan with
Ray Rice it was me Aaron Ziggler Mike
Felder and Josh circle and Ray Rice what
a group
somewhere you know what I'm the only one
still employed in football
that's not true nay glorious I'm just
I'm just trying to be funny Nagler great
covers the Packers simply following him
all of you are right oh god dude alright
well the next one from from our be if
ture decides to leave Alabama would it
make more sense for from to stay another
year at Georgia to have a better chance
to improve his draft stock and make it
to the college football playoffs so I
think that from and tour are such
different levels that they don't need to
look at each other like you know from
the 5 2009 like you you're not in the
same level guys I think Fromm needs to
make his decision based on it he needs
to think more in the Jordan love Jacob
Eason tier of yeah where does he fit in
that group but if there isn't like
another quarterback added to the 2021
draft you're already looking at to uh
probably Justin fields probably Trevor
Lawrence at best Jake from can be QB
four in that draft so I think if tua
does decide to go back to Alabama if I'm
sitting there and I'm Drake from I say I
have to compete with Jacob Eason I
already beat him out once
Justin Herbert Jordan luff I'm gonna
compete with those guys because I mean I
haven't done a lot of work on next
year's group and I'm sure that Jake
Fromm's not sitting there saying who's
coming out next year but he could slide
into the first round of this draft I
think next year when you're gonna have
three very good quarterbacks who were
your three I have to uh Justin fields
Trevor Lawrence Jamie Newman's going to
Oregon it sounds like you got to worry
about that a little bit yeah he's got a
lot of talent I I think I think Fromm
should leave I'm leaning that way but I
think whenever if it's next year or this
year like he's not like everyone wants
to look at Joe burrow or Baker Mayfield
and like the the Rises that they had
they both like Joe burrow is there still
outliers
right n8 Joe burrow has better traits
than shake romic Jake from six two of
the bad arm yeah you look at like drew
lock who if he would have come out as a
junior probably would have been a second
round pick goes back to Missouri to try
to improve his draft stock has a pretty
good year
here's the second round pick playing
very well with Denver right now but
didn't really do much for his draft
stock I think when you get to
quarterbacks
especially guys that are four-year
starters kind of know who you are like
what more do I need to see at Georgia
from Jake from I agree this dude has two
questions which I love which three draft
prospects would you select to make your
all-decade squad for the 2010 s one
offense one defense one special teams I
am gonna cheat and go first special
teams is Justin Tucker
no yeah special teams the greatest
kicker of all time if these are as a
prospect or like with the hindsight of
yeah what we know now obviously I I
would take Patrick mahomes but if I'm
looking at him as a prospect I hated him
so I'm gonna say Andrew Luck was a very
good quarterback prospect and I'm just
hoping that maybe he keeps playing
football yeah I think so actually
because of my grading scale I can look
at this and see my top rated players in
this era would have been Andrew Luck on
offense and Von Miller on defense yeah
or you could even go I think Cleo Mack
on defense so I didn't have him that
item is like the number five player in
that draft yeah I mean I didn't have him
in that draft cuz I wasn't doing this
but I mean just looking back from what
we know now so clowny yeah yep Connor
who yeah you've been doing this since
like what 2016 yeah I would say I've
been doing grading enough players to
start in 2016 I think the highest guy on
defense would be Nick Bosa ironically I
really do I'm trying to think Jamal
Adams was close item two that year was
of Williams II nope Jalen was like seven
or six for me that year it's probably
Nick Bosa offense I don't say no would
be Quintin Nelson item number one item
number one that year and say Kwan number
two somebody tags me in a tweet today
off topic that said the difference
between Quinton Nelson at one and then
the next guard is the largest gap of any
position in football
oh man maybe who's the next guard who's
I mean it's clearly random Brooks and
then Brandon Brooks yeah so for any
other position I think he's probably
right
this year Stephon Gilmore at corner IP
but Trey white was so free white was
very good and even Jalen Ramsey I think
once he bounces back Anna's may become I
mean that might be it might be the
biggest difference I'm trying to think
that's a great question yeah I would you
know what miles Garrett is really high
for me as well well I'm looking back at
old scouting lists here oh yes miles
Garrett was yeah miles was a consensus
number one yeah
consensus number one player okay all
right special teams I don't know what's
I don't know it's Justin Tucker that's
just that's who it is Roberto Aguayo
anyone definitely [ __ ] kickers Dakota
Cox my favorite little Alabama beat
redder is what and not know where you're
going with that my favorite little
Alabama be coder is what LSU's doing
sustainable or will their success all
depend on if they can get a star
quarterback to replace burro
I think Dakota as an Alabama fan this is
a good question for you I think it
depends out of Joe Brady States because
you like we've talked about with Alabama
before to ax it was like oh my god if
they could get a quarterback ironically
enough it was always the same deal with
LSU they got one they went undefeated
and so I think it just matters are you
gonna keep Joe Brady or Garron seems to
think they are which is fantastic so if
you keep him you have a good very good
offensive staff and you should be able
to develop if not you know get the
transfer type guys in so I think that it
is sustainable because LSU has been good
for 20 years this isn't a new thing you
know when Nick Saban then won a national
championship they've been close since
then you're always gonna get talent
because Louisiana is a hotbed for
college football you can dip into Texas
you can dip into Florida so I think it
is sustainable but it how successful
they are each year is gonna depend on
quarterback yeah and I do think that
eventually they're gonna have to give
Brady this offense and the title and a
lot of money to keep him around I don't
know how much longer you can do that and
I don't know how much I trust coach o to
continue that success so I do think it's
sustainable I don't think we're gonna
see LSU do a run
like what we have Alabama or you know
schools like USC in the past I I do
think that for the next couple years LSU
is gonna be looking to be one of the
better teams in the country even even
next year I think they're gonna come
back with a lot of talent
very good recruiting classes and miles
Brennan already said he's staying he's
gonna be a very good quarterback who
we've already seen a little bit this
year it kind of reminds me of Alabama
not Alabama Oklahoma back when they had
like Jason White like 90s version
Oklahoma when they were really starting
to build things back they just started
getting all these quarterbacks and who
knows Jason White Josh Heupel you know
Bradford and it's just continuing so
maybe that's what we see at LSU yeah I
think if anything else he was kind of
underachieved
this last decade you know after they won
that championship LSU recruits great
football players you look at all them in
the NFL I mean we just talked about some
of them as Hall of Fame you have Pat
Peet there I mean obviously Jamal Adams
they've had great great football players
so now it's about as you guys said
keeping the staff and keeping this going
they're gonna start stealing some
recruits because of how legendary this
year has been so I think they're in a
good drivers seat right now to be a top
dog for a little while and I'm excited
to see what Myles Brennan looks like I
mean kind of a different player from Joe
burrow and it might a seasoned redshirt
sophomore now so we'll get two years of
him potentially so you have a little bit
of time to try to get your guy but I'll
say I as a Texas fan you do get a little
bit of a when Texas had Vince Young and
it was like oh my god
we're gonna be a dynasty and then when
Vince Young leaves it's like ah even
with Colt McCoy they made it back to a
championship but it fell off I could see
that happening to LSU where you get the
best player to ever come through your
system and you win an a/d and trying to
recreate that it's so hard to do and you
could be good I don't think LSU will
ever fall to where Texas was with
Charlie but I think it's something that
you have like Florida with Tim Tebow
yeah you got it it was lightning in a
bottle for a couple years with LSU might
be one or two we'll see what happens
with Brandon and then you're right like
they're always gonna recruit on the
defensive line linebackers skill
positions will be there I just don't
know if you can keep it going like this
on offense Antonio
Meeta last question what can we expect
from some of the teams that don't have
first-round picks bears Texans Rams
Steelers are the teams that right now
don't and I think with the Bears they
have two second-round picks that don't
expect them to trade up the Texans only
have one pick I think in the top 100 I
don't think we're gonna trade up the
Rams have the right trade their entire
right draft before it and the Steelers I
mean historically are not an aggressive
team they were last year obviously with
trading up and then trading from Inc up
but I think with Chicago we've already
seen Ryan pace a that Mitch will be the
quarterback I think they're gonna try to
bolster that offensive line and maybe
add a corner in the second round with
Houston that's also a team that needs to
think about offensive line they need to
think about corner they just locked up
Whitney Marcellus so they're in good
position there the Rams if they can't
keep Corey Littleton but a linebacker
becomes the need but that is it should
be offensive line every pick that they
have and maybe edge with Dante Fowler
and then this
I think the Steelers are really
interesting because do they believe in
James Connor what type of pressure do
they feel to get a quarterback of the
future now this is a team that I didn't
mike tomlin it should be in the coach of
the year running in the top two or three
votes because of what he's done but you
have to start thinking about restocking
you know James Connor was banged up a
lot this year so I would draft a running
back at some point and I think they have
some dogs in that secondary obviously
but I still think the secondary is in
need yeah and without having a
first-round pick I think that changes a
lot for Pittsburgh I think that if they
had a first-round pick then they would
probably target a quarterback with the
second but they don't so I don't know if
they do roll the dice there I think
they're probably waiting to see how
healthy has been Roethlisberger how many
more years does he plan on playing I
can't imagine it's in two years I think
you have to have a plan in place for
what are we doing afterwards because
Mason Rudolph didn't work out
duck Hodges isn't working out you need
another quarterback in there I just
don't know if they do it with the
second-round pick
yeah I think when you look at the
Steelers the sweet spot for them and
this draft should be to get a running
back James Connors just been so beat up
this year and they want to run the ball
a lot so I think they can capitalize on
the value there
the Rams I mean they just trade all
their draft picks but they definitely
need to get younger on that offensive
line or honestly
just better so I mean you look at these
groups it's it's tough Chicago is
interesting because I think we're in
that group that we don't think they'll
take a quarterback with one of those
second-round picks I really don't see it
yeah it's I think those teams are really
interesting and I'm sorry I misspoke the
Rams have 52 and 84 it's the Texans they
have one pick in the top 100 at 57
overall so not a lot of assets for those
teams all right that is our show we will
be back next week everything is back to
normal mellow goes back to school we get
back on a regular schedule okay
Monday afternoon Wednesday morning and
Friday morning stick to football and
guys I don't know if you've noticed look
at the calendar 18 days from right now
we will be in Mobile Alabama for the
start of your bowl that day ironically
enough January 20th
the deadline for underclassmen to enter
and withdrawal from the NFL Draft so
it's gonna be an exciting next couple
weeks as we break down head coaching
hires all the moves that are happening
in the NFL and college football from
ello and Connor thanks for hanging out
with this we'll see you soon